People don't actually understand that if you stop giving a single F
your life gets so much better
7 reasons you should stop giving a fuck
number 1 we really don't live that long
so you might as well enjoy your life while you live it
we won't be around forever
so none of this is gonna matter anyways
care about your legacy and the way you live life
but truly none of it matters
the only thing that truly matters is the way you live your life every day.
Are you honorable, respectful, truthful?
Do people love you and do you love the people around you?
number two why you should stop giving a
nobody thinks about you as much as you do
most people are so consumed with themselves
that they don't really think about you as much as you probably think they do
They don't really care.. so why should you?
number 3 everything that you learn from life is from making mistakes.
Everything you became good at
you were once bad at
So why worry about making mistakes?
number 4. If you wouldn't take advice from them..
why are you listening to their criticism?
We hold on to words that other people say
But do we really care about them?
You probably shouldn't.
No. 5  99% of your regrets are the things that you choose to not do.
Risk you don't take, things you don't say
Things you didn't do.
So stop being afraid to take risk
if you don't wanna have any regrets.
number 6 and I know this one is a hard one for most people
but if you cannot control it
let it go
it does not serve you
stop caring literally
say F it
Lastly, the most important things in life are achieved not by caring more
but by caring less.
Wishing you were more of something actually makes you less of that.
For example, wishing you were happy actually makes you unhappy
Essentially just stop giving a f about anything and start living your life happily
Because truly none of this matters
all the minute details that you're stressing and worrying about do NOT matter
Just be happy.